c'est l'heure de notre second débat dans
ce sens public consacré ce soir au
maintien de l'ordre en France les
manifestations qui ont suivi l'usage du
49,3 pour adopter la réforme des
retraites on fait resurgir le spectre
des violences des gilets jaunes et les
accusations sur une réponse policière
disproportionnée avant de décortiquer la
doctrine française retour sur un
dérapage c'était le 15 avril dernier à
Rennes Fabien Ricard a retrouvé le
principal témoin c'est une journaliste
photo reporter
ces images ont fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux le 15 avril à Rennes en marge
d'une manifestation contre la réforme
des retraites cet homme est violemment
plaqué au sol par 6 CRS témoin de la
scène une journaliste interpelle alors
les fonctionnaires
vous allez la sucer comme ça c'est
interdit des pièces
tu es un malade je suis journaliste
on est maintenant
la journaliste c'était elle Anna
Marguerita photographe couvrait ce
jour-là la manifestation à Rennes pour
une agence de presse j'ai remarqué
qu'une femme se faisait interpeller avec
une grande violence au niveau de cette
rue là donc je suis resté alors que le
cortège se dirigeait ailleurs pour
filmer cette interpellation donc ça
c'est la la photo qui précède vraiment
l'interpellation de l'homme qu'on va en
arrière-plan alors qu'il essaie de
réagir à l'interpellation de cette femme
qui a été plaquée au sol et menotté
également choqué par la violence de
l'interpellation de l'homme au pantalon
blanc anatante de s'interposer avant
d'être à son tour violemment pris à
partie par un CRS j'ai remarqué qu'un
genou avait été placé sur son dos et
qu'un autre genou avait été placé sur
son cou et juste avant juste avant ça
j'entendais l'homme poussait des cris de
douleur il était complètement immobilisé
il les mettait aucune résistance il ne
pouvait pas c'est une technique
d'immobilisation qui n'est pas interdite
en France mais qui pourtant peut causer
la mort et donc
j'ai essayé de m'interposer verbalement
en tout cas pas physiquement
avec son lance grenade vraiment
pourtant en fait sur ma tête quoi sur
d'autres images le même fonctionnaire
mettant joue les manifestants avec la
même arme un lance-grenade multicou qui
peut envoyer plusieurs grenades dans
l'espace de quelques secondes donc qui
qui serait une arme létale si elle était
utilisée à ce moment-là c'est un geste
qui est complètement disproportionné il
me hurle en même temps tu dégages tu
dégages alors que je me tenais à une
distance quand même raisonnable de la
scène selon le journal Ouest France
plusieurs témoins ont affirmé que
l'homme interpellé n'avait pas montré de
comportement violent impossible de juger
le bien-fondé de l'interpellation sans
connaître le contexte rappelle ce
chercheur spécialiste du maintien de
l'ordre mais même si cette dernière
était justifiée il constate un usage
disproportionné de la force la technique
d'interpellation avec effectivement le
genou sur la gorge ou à proximité de la
gorge ça c'est dangereux le policier qui
met sans sa ranger sur la cheville du
manifestant produit de la douleur
totalement inutile et puis bien sûr il y
a le fou furieux on peut pas la plus
autrement qui part bille en tête contre
la journaliste le simple fait qu'il a
été porteur de cette arme à bout portant
directement en horizontalité alors même
que les conditions d'emploi
réglementaires stipulent qu'il faut que
l'arme soit 45 degrés et que le viseur
donc soit en l'air montre que déjà ce
policier était en faute même s'il n'y
avait pas de grenades lacrymogène dans
son lanceur de grenade sur la base des
images tournées par Anna Margherita le
député insoumis Frédéric Mathieu a saisi
le procureur de la République dans un
communiqué publié le jour même la
préfecture d'Ille-et-Vilaine s'est
contentée de rappeler que la
manifestation n'était pas déclarée et a
annoncé 11 interpellations pour violence
arène le 15 avril
voilà et on a évidemment proposé à la
préfecture d'Ille-et-Vilaine de
participer à ce reportage sans obtenir
de réponse je vous présente mes invités
tout de suite Mathilde de l'arrière
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes historienne
spécialiste des mouvements
révolutionnaires au 19e siècle et du
maintien de l'ordre en France et
maîtresse de conférence à l'Université
Gustave Eiffel Frédéric et si bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes chef du
service de communication de la police
nationale Christian Moana bonsoir
sociologue et chercheur au CNRS et
Mathilde Sirault est évidemment resté à
mes côtés je commence avec vous Frédéric
lessive peut-être une réaction à ce à ce
reportage on le disait quand on regarde
et on en reçoit souvent une vidéo
montrant des violences qui semblent
illégitimes des forces de l'ordre il y a
toujours la question du contexte il nous
manque souvent le contexte mais là dans
l'histoire qu'on vient de raconter on
voit mal ce qui peut justifier la
réaction des policiers quand même
pardonnerez de pas forcément parler de
ces faits en particulier même si je peux
je peux les je peux les commenter
certains appellation je ne dirais pas
que c'est celle va montrer comme un pur
exemple de technique policières une fois
qu'on a dit ça
alors malgré tout on n'est pas sur sur
un dérapage je vous dis ce sont
simplement pas forcément les techniques
qu'on voudrait exactement avoir pour
être le plus efficace possible la
réalité c'est quand même que les
techniques sont systématiquement
destinés à procéder une interpellation
la plus propre possible en n'étant pas
dans des techniques qui vont être
douloureuses vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure aussi des modèles des modèles
extérieurs vous rappelez de la polémique
qui avait pu avoir il y a moins de deux
ans et demi l'évolution des clés des
clés d'interpellation des clés de
contrôle de tête et autres les
techniques policières ont aussi évolué
pour s'adapter pour être le plus
le plus respecté possible l'intégrité
physique et puis vous avez parfois des
individus qui résistent qui opposent une
force importante à l'interpellation et
ensuite parfois sur le terrain
évidemment toujours un peu compliqué je
vais prendre une citation d'Emmanuel
Macron en récente c'était dans son
interview chez nos confrères du Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France le 23 avril
dernier début de semaine je récuse le
terme de violences policières ni le
prénom de la République la police et la
gendarmerie dans le monopole de ce qu'on
appelle la violence légitime elle
protège le citoyen s'oppose à ces gens
au comportement inacceptable Mathilde la
réaction si on commence par les mots
est-ce que vous vous employez ces termes
de violence policière bah oui parce que
il décrivent bien ce que d'un nombre
incalculable d'image de chiffres
d'enquête des montres il y a
effectivement des violences policières
donc je vois pas par récuser le terme de
toute façon ça n'enlève pas la réalité
donc oui je l'emploi et et je le déplore
qui plus est la situation qu'on a montré
dans dans le reportage on est on est
complètement en infraction avec tout un
tas de de techniques du code de
procédure pénale enfin ça va pas du tout
que ce soit à la clé que ça soit la
menace contre la journaliste mais bon il
y en a il y en a plein d'autres
et je pense pas non plus que enfin je
commence en avoir un peu assez de du
monopole de de Max Weber par par un
certain nombre de de politique dire que
il faut expliquer dire que la police les
forces de l'ordre on ne monopole létale
monopole de la violence légitime ne
saurait en aucun cas signifier que elles
sont légitimes à utiliser n'importe quel
violence et par ailleurs quand Max Weber
dit cette phrase c'est parce qu'il
constate un processus de construction de
l'État moderne et c'est pas prescriptif
il dit pas que l'État doit être violent
et qu'il est légitime à le faire et en
fait enfin
la règle d'un état de droit c'est que la
violence doit être d'abord absolument
nécessaire et ensuite proportionné et là
très clairement je crois qu'ils le
disent dans le reportage c'est parce que
l'on a alors si on essaye de généraliser
Christian Moana on va essayer de se
comparer un peu est-ce que effectivement
sur ce principe de la proportionnalité
est-ce qu'elle est selon vous moins
respectée en France que dans d'autres
pays par exemple en Europe alors c'est
difficile à dire parce que les règles
d'intervention sont très différentes
d'un pays à l'autre ce qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'en France on avait un modèle de
maintien de l'ordre français qui
jusqu'au début des années 2000 était
plutôt monté en montré en exemple à
l'échelle européenne au moins et que
depuis quelques années on avait fait
plutôt figure de mauvais élèves de la
classe européenne encore une fois avec
notamment des réflexions qui ont été
menées dans d'autres pays à laquelle la
France ne sait pas associer sur comment
faire évoluer le maintien de l'ordre et
pour mémoire quand même un certain
nombre de condamnations de de la police
française par des instances européennes
donc ça se sait ça se voit à l'extérieur
quand on parle avec des collègues il y a
une image je parle pour l'instant de
l'image de la police nationale qui s'est
extrêmement dégradée je parle en termes
de maintien de l'ordre alors qu'on avait
plutôt un modèle qui était montré en
exemple parce que on savait intervenir
sans causer trop de blessés trop de
morts et là on voit que il y a plutôt un
sentiment de montée en puissance de la
violence policière Mathilde et comment
on peut expliquer justement cette
bascule un modèle qui était plutôt pris
en exemple et maintenant qui serait
décrié à quel moment qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pour que pour qu'il y ait un
changement de cette peinture pour
l'historienne Mathilde oui oui même si
moi je travaille sur des périodes plus
intérieures mais en fait il y a un
moment c'est à dire que autour des des
années
2005-2010 à un moment où suite à une
évolution des des formes manifestantes
qui sont documentées et que les que les
autorités et les forces de l'ordre
constatent à partir de là donc on voit
que voilà la forme rituelle de la
manifestation avec ses cortèges bien
organisé par les syndicats temps à
disparaître il y a une volonté d'essayer
de trouver des solutions et là il y a
deux voies différentes la voie qui va
donner dont on parlait mon collègue donc
le le l'espace de réflexion européen ça
s'appelle godiac
de 2010 à 2013 et qui va essayer de
trouver des réponses à cette évolution
des formes protestataires mais par la
désescalade pour avec comme objectif que
la première chose que doit faire la
police enfin les forces de l'ordre dans
un état de droit c'est de faciliter la
manifestation parce que c'est un droit
démocratique et pas d'empêcher la
manifestation et donc d'apaiser les
tensions etc à l'inverse la France prend
une autre solution mais parce que elle
ne tire aucune leçon de ce qui s'est
passé en 2005 lors des émeutes de 2005
il y a quelque chose qui est que 10
plusieurs chercheurs mais que il y a
dans la police une espèce de fermeture
aux sciences sociales et aux travaux des
chercheurs une fermeture
le terme de citadelle a siéger revient
souvent et résultat on ne tire pas les
leçons des échecs des dispositifs de
maintien de l'ordre en France comme
ailleurs mais je vous donne entendre
Frédéric lessive parce que je crois que
dans votre histoire personnelle vous
avez participé euh à des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre ou au sein des CRS
c'est peut-être ce que j'appellerai mon
cœur de métier effectivement c'est leur
public et la sécurité publique mais je
voudrais revenir sur si vous motorisez
sur sur quelques quelques propos le cœur
le cœur de de la doctrine française
c'est le maintien de l'ordre c'est
d'abord et avant tout destiné à garantir
la liberté d'expression et le droit de
manifester on est en train d'indiquer un
petit peu que nous serions le vilain
petit canard dans les pays européens
notre principe le cœur de de notre
action c'est celui-là il ne faut pas il
ne faut pas détourner trop trop les
choses c'est pas d'accord les uns et les
autres dans les arguments de chacun
nationalité de maintien de l'ordre qui a
été fait en deux temps décembre 2020 et
2021 il le rappelle clairement c'est cet
objectif la graduation de l'usage de la
force et sa proportionnalité ce sont les
principes fondamentaux on a même voulu
aussi réinsister sur des principes de
dialogue de communication avec les
organisateurs du manifestation parce que
si un service d'ordre si des
interventions policières sont mal
compris par les manifestants on peut
avoir des situations et des incidents
qui sont générés simplement par
l'incompréhension des manœuvres
policières qui sont en train d'être
engagés donc le voilà je voudrais pas
qu'on laisse croire que on suit une
route tout à fait inverse aux démocratie
et le modèle français n'est pas aussi
décrié qu'il est qu'il vient d'être
décrit parce que nous avons des forces
spécialisées qui sont là non pas pour
être en train de réprimer les
manifestations comme j'ai pu entendre
mais garantir leur libre exercice et ne
réagir qu'à des dérapages et à des
violences qui seraient commises moi
j'entends vos arguments tranquillement
mais les deux autres invités sont à la
limite du de la moquerie
je souris parce que pour
ce serait de la langue de bois ce serait
totalement fou j'aimerais juste
comprendre mais effectivement dans la
pratique et d'ailleurs il y a même un
message qui est parti du ministère de
l'Intérieur rappelant un certain nombre
de règles aux policiers et au préfet
puisqu'il y a eu quand même des usages
abusifs de l'interdiction de manifester
qui a été d'ailleurs il y a eu une
intervention du conseil de l'État et
donc le ministère de l'Intérieur a réagi
tout ça pour dire que en théorie il y a
des choses dans la pratique ce qu'on
voit et pour revenir peut-être un peu
sur ce qui a été dit on voit un vrai
tournant et qu'on peut dater assez
précisément c'est les manifestations de
la loi travail en 2016 où là on a et
c'est avant les gilets jaunes excusez
moi mais c'est important on a donc des
organisations qui ont l'habitude de
manifester des syndicats des partis
politiques et qui vont protester contre
cette loi et qui sont surpris eux-mêmes
par la surréaction policière alors qu'on
peut expliquer est-ce que c'est pas
aussi parce qu'il y a plus de violence
dans les magnifiques donc justement
c'est pour ça que je suis avant les
gilets jaunes parce que avant les gilets
jaunes on est à face à des
manifestations qui ne sont pas violentes
mais il y a un choix politique du
gouvernement de Manuel Valls de
donc ça fait bien longtemps quand
j'étais reporter des manifestations où
il y avait des violences quasiment à
chaque fin de cortège avec des pillages
de magasins etc on peut pas nier
absolument c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est que il y a toujours eu des
violences dans les manifestations depuis
on peut remonter à Mai 68 où il y a des
violences très très fortes ce que je
veux dire c'est que on perçoit de
manière très claire et quand on
interview des CRS de terrain on a la
même chose un changement dans les
stratégies policières c'est un peu de ça
qu'on parle ce soir qui sont à partir de
2016 qui avec un changement très net
avec la multiplication des Nass alors
que on était vers un abandon des nazes à
ce moment-là le cercle on est la
stratégie dit de la tronçonneuse où on
coupe des cortèges de manifestants etc
etc alors même qu'on est dans des
moments et des lieux où il y a pas de
violence et donc évidemment
pourquoi pour des raisons politiques des
raisons de choix stratégiques de
centralisation parce que maintenant la
préfecture de police tu veux tout
contrôler donc on laisse peu de marge de
manœuvre aux gens sur le terrain et tout
ça fait que on a un raidissement et
qu'évidemment au moment des gilets
jaunes où là il y a des gens qui
viennent manifester qui ne sont pas
antipolismes mais qui sont surpris par
les réactions policières et on s'engage
dans une spirale de violence il s'agit
pas de nier les violences des
manifestants mais il y a ce qui s'est
passé à l'arc de tri enfin quand même
absolument mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir la jeunesse comment au
départ on part d'un mouvement totalement
désorganisé et c'est un problème pour
les policiers d'avoir face à des
manifestations il y a pas
d'organisateurs
ce désordre et la surréaction entraîne
cette fille alors je vais vous redonner
la parole tout de suite je vous propose
de d'entendre de verser à notre débat
une analyse celle de Fabien Jobard qui
est directeur de recherche au CNRS lui
alors il va plutôt dans votre sens il
affirme que les dérapages des forces de
l'ordre ne viennent pas forcément
d'individus isolés écoutez question se
pose effectivement de savoir si la
police
toujours sous contrôle de l'État
souvent on dit lorsqu'il y a une bavure
policière mais c'est le fait d'un seul
un dérapage individuel une situation
personnelle particulière etc mais là ce
sont des brigades entières sont des
compagnies entières la police n'est plus
en mesure de maîtriser ces troupes il y
a des troupes que qu'elle maîtrise il y
en a d'autres qu'elle ne maîtrisent pas
ou beaucoup moins bien
les troupes qu'elle maîtrise sont les
gendarmes mobiles les CRS troupes
qu'elle maîtrise moins ce sont toutes
celles qui ont été formés aux violences
urbaines et qu'on voit apparaître là en
première ligne de des opérations menées
par exemple par les braves m les
brigades motorisés de la préfecture de
police Mathilde Lasserre est-ce qu'il y
a des troupes donc là on est au delà
d'un cas isolé des troupes que pour
reprendre les termes qui ne sont pas qui
échappent au contrôle de l'État je
reprends les termes de de Fabien Jobard
alors je pense pas qu'il va y dire
échappe au contrôle à l'état ce qui se
pose de savoir si la police est toujours
sous contrôle de l'État c'est qu'il y a
plusieurs forces qui interviennent sur
le terrain il y a des forces qui sont
formées au maintien de l'ordre et dans
le processus historique de modération de
la violence publique l'un par la
l'invention de force spécialisée dans le
maintien de l'ordre donc les CRS et la
gendarmerie mobile maintenant ça fait
partie du processus de débrutalisation
parce que une force qui est un des
hommes des corps qui sont préparés au
maintien de l'ordre et on le sait que
dans cette formation il s'agit par
exemple d'encaisser les coûts ça fait
partie de la formation des CRS lors d'un
module ça fait partie de la
débrbrutalisation donc il y a des CRS il
y a des gendarmes mobiles qui sont
déplacés et interviennent sur sur les
lieux de d'affrontements et puis il y a
des forces qui sont locales et qui ne
sont pas forcément formés au maintien de
l'ordre c'est le cas des compagnies
d'intervention c'est le cas aussi de la
BAC qui n'est pas formé pour le maintien
de l'ordre mais pour des violences ur
quant à la bravène c'est une force odire
de Didier l'Allemand qui a surtout
d'interpellation et d'interpellation qui
est toujours réduire de d'idéalement ont
surtout un objectif communicationnel
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut pouvoir donner
du chiffre un nombre d'interpellation
qui va s'afficher en bandeau au pied de
des chaînes télévisées et qui va faire
l'objet de tweet sachant que la plupart
des gens interpellaient ne seront pas
par la suite poursuivies c'est un
changement important cette cette
multiplication des interpellations ça et
en fait c'est la création de la bravème
et la brême et elle-même créatrice de
désordre donc en fait c'est très
variable
d'ailleurs c'est le titre du livre de
Jobard la fabrique du désordre donc
parce qu'effectivement si vous avez une
par exemple une manifestation voilà
basse intensité et au milieu on une
poubelle brûle et une charge de la brave
rentre dans la manifestation et va
saisir l'individu mais au passage en
matraquant les gens qui sont sur le côté
ça va créer une logique de foule qui va
se tellement créer plus de désordre
c'est des psychologues de sociaux de
Britanniques qui document de ça très
bien donc en fait certaines
interventions de police sont
fautrices et créent du désordre ce que
d'ailleurs il y a je vous l'avais
peut-être vu il y a à la fois un
documentaire enfin un article de
Mediapart et un documentaire où on voit
des CRS donc des forces de l'ordre formé
au maintien de l'ordre qui disent à des
braves mais c'est n'importe quoi ce que
vous faites vous êtes en train de créer
du désordre il y a même des conflits à
l'intérieur évidemment vous vouliez vous
voulez réagir est-ce que vous vous
faites le lien entre
ce ces critiques qui sont va être et ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est à
dire un climat de de violence exacerbée
aussi subi par ses policiers je vais
essayer de revenir sur quelques points
sur les sociétés j'étais en opposition
frontale
la doctrine de maintien d'ordre elle ne
change pas entre la première dizaine en
gros de journée nationale d'action
contre les retraites et le 16 le 16 mars
ce sont exactement les mêmes policiers
exactement les mêmes autorités qui sont
simplement dans l'obligation d'adapter
leur posture à l'agressivité et au fait
que on en arrive à des manifestations
qui sont beaucoup plus spontanés entre
guillemets parce qu'il y a eu le 43
entre temps et donc il y a une réaction
à ce choix politique mais en tout cas la
stratégie elle est la même le fait
d'avoir mis des effectifs à distance et
d'être obligé d'aller beaucoup plus
proche des individus qui ne sont plus le
même public manifestant on n'est plus
dans le même caractère globalement
Pacifique c'est aussi à l'origine et
quand j'entends madame larrière qui nous
est dit que la braderie me fonce dans le
tas en quelque sorte c'est parce qu'il y
a un petit feu de poubelle au milieu au
milieu de la chaussée je sais pas on n'a
pas dû voir les mêmes choses à la
télévision ou sur dans les rues de nos
villes il y a des commissariats qui ont
été attaqués à Lorient une
sous-préfecture des mairies qui ont été
partiellement incendiés il y a plus d'un
millier de policiers je suis peut-être
candide mais je crois pas que
plus d'un millier de policiers blessés
absolument pas de moi si plus d'un
millier de policiers blessés donc voilà
ça je voulais quand même revenir dessus
parce que ça me semblait essentiel un
mot sur les noces ce que vous appuyez
les noces ce sont essentiellement des
manoeuvres policières qui sont destinées
à procéder à des interpellations donc
elles sont privatives de liberté en
elle-même mais elles se font sous
l'autorité lorsqu'on procède à ses
interpellations de groupe d'individus
pour un attroupement pour autre chose on
va procéder des interpellations et donc
la privation de liberté elle va débuter
au moment où on aura encerclé ces
individus ça c'est une ça c'est une
première chose et je pense qu'il faut
pas caricaturer ce type de technique on
évoquait le fait de tronçonner souvent
vous avez une attaque qui consiste à
dire mais enfin pourquoi vous
n'interpellez pas juste les casseurs au
lieu de de perturber l'ensemble de la
manifestation lorsque vous évoquez j'ai
fait de tronçonner entre guillemets en
tout cas le fait de bloquer
momentanément un cortège quand vous avez
tout un halo de casseurs qui sont en
tête de cortège et qui sont en train à
chaque fois que vous avez la tentative
pour les interpeller parce que ça je
pense que l'essentiel des forces de
l'ordre c'est aussi de mettre fin à ses
troubles pour que la manif revienne à un
fonctionnement serein ben oui ça
s'appelle aussi tronçonner la manif d'où
l'importance de ce que soulignait tout à
l'heure c'est à dire il faut communiquer
avec les organisateurs si ça se fait
sans communication ça paraît comme
quelque chose d'incompréhensible où on
perturbe nous même la manifestation mais
la transformer en une doctrine de des
forces de l'ordre qui savent le désordre
je peux pas être d'accord avec cette
vision des choses alors on reviendra là
dessus on reviendra notamment sur le sur
les Nass et peut-être aussi un peu sur
la bravée même et si on y a déjà
consacré du temps mais on va se
concentrer maintenant avec vous Mathilde
sur la personnalité du préfet Laurent
Nunez qui on pourrait presque dire que
la en tout cas la dernière partie de la
mobilisation contre la forme des
retraites à sonner le gars d'une forme
d'état de grâce oui Thomas après l'air
du très clivant Didier l'allemand au
poste sensible de préfet de police de
Paris on en a parlé à l'instant la
nomination de Laurent Nunez ancien
secrétaire d'État auprès de Christophe
Castaner à Beauvau avait plutôt été
perçu comme un signe d'apaisement un
retour voilà une nouvelle méthode un
tempérament différent une stratégie
déployée sur le terrain qui a tout de
suite montré aussi une certaine rupture
CRS et gendarmes mobiles en appui des
unités mobiles mais au plus près des
manifestants stratégies de la mise à
distance et de l'évitement du contact
physique riposte proportionné et
jusqu'ici il est débordements et les
scènes d'émeutes ont globalement pu être
évités durant la contestation mais au
fur et à mesure du conflit contre les
retraites on l'a vu des témoignages des
vidéos montrant des comportements
parfois violents et inappropriés de
membres de force de l'ordre contre des
manifestants ou des journalistes ont pu
ternir l'image et les débuts plutôt
maîtrisés de Laurent douniase qui
s'échine bien sûr à défendre ses troupes
les polémiques on en parle sur les sur
les braves m également on contraint
l'ancien patron de la lutte contre le
terrorisme à s'expliquer sur les
pratiques de cette brigade et puis il y
a évidemment un grand test qu'on a tous
en tête c'est le défi de la sécurité
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris
effectivement l'image du maintien de
l'ordre on l'a dit de notre pays et
plutôt dégradé depuis la réforme de la
loi du travail mais aussi les gilets
jaunes les débordements du Stade de
France en mai dernier également alors
pour les Jeux Olympiques le mot d'ordre
est clair plus de bleu sur le terrain
donc le premier enjeu sera d'abord de
former de recruter des effectifs
suffisants sachant que la délinquance
les violentes les violences faites aux
personnes restent élevées Laurent Nunez
est un homme de confiance d'Emmanuel
Macron il a d'ailleurs adhéré à son
parti en 2019 il est plutôt apprécié du
côté de l'univers macroniste et certains
le verrai même Thomas embrassait une
carrière côté politique après tous ces
tous ces enjeux à son poste on parle de
lui notamment pour les futurs élections
municipales à Marseille où il où il fut
préfet de police entre 2015 et 2017 son
nom avait d'ailleurs déjà circulé pour
les législatives en juin dernier merci
beaucoup Mathilde je reviens sur le
calendrier je reste avec vous Mathilde
larrête de la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites effectivement ce
que disait Frédéric lichy tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que il y a une dizaine de
manifestations qui se passent qui se
passe bien et puis effectivement à
partir du moment où il y a ce sentiment
d'un passage en force de de l'exécutif
le 49-3 peut-être un degré de violence
supplémentaire dans les dans les
manifestations est-ce que ça justifie la
réponse policière je ne sais pas mais
est-ce que vous l'analysez comme ça
non en fait moi j'analyserai surtout que
le passage aux 49-3 il montre que le
gouvernement ne parvient pas à gouverner
ou à réformer en l'occurrence avec un
reposant sur le consentement et en fait
quand on lit alors je pense par exemple
aux travaux de la philosophe
Hélène elle elle démontre que moins un
gouvernement parvient à gouverner sur le
consentement plus il a recours à la
force en fait la force de l'ordre le
recours à la force de l'ordre est
utilisé pour pallier le déficit
d'autorité et finalement la faiblesse de
l'État et donc en fait ce qui se passe
avec le 49-3 c'est qu'on est dans cette
situation de de déficit de légitimité et
d'autorité et qui est d'ailleurs
ressenti aussi par et par le
gouvernement mais aussi par évidemment
d'abord par les manifestants et résultat
il y a un envoi supérieur de la force
parce qu'il ne reste plus que ça d'une
certaine façon
donc
ça justifie le surcroît de violence des
manifestants ou de certains manifestants
mais en fait la question enfin non mais
j'essaye de décortiquer ce qui s'est
passé je l'avais apporté parce que elle
est quand même très utile petite
citation il y a 3 sortes de violence la
première mère de toutes les autres et la
violence institutionnelle celle qui
l'égalisent et perpétuer domination les
oppressions et les exploitations celles
qui écrase et la mine des millions
d'hommes dans des rouages silencieux et
bien au milieu la deuxième et la
violence révolutionnaire qui naît de la
volonté d'abolir la première la
troisième et la bouleur violence
répressive qui a pour objet d'étouffer
la seconde en se faisant l'auxiliaire et
la complice de la première violence qui
engendre toutes les autres il n'y a pas
pierrypocrisie de napper violence que la
seconde enseignant d'oublier la première
qu'il a fait l'être et la troisième
qu'il a tue c'est un évêque catholique
brésilien donne Herder Camara qui a fait
cette jambe et en fait cette
démonstration mais si je j'imagine un
commerçant qui nous écoutent qui a eu sa
vitrine cassée par des manifestants au
soir du 49-3 ils vont ils disent elle
est bien gentil la dame mais
heureusement qu'il y avait les policiers
pour me protéger par ailleurs mais là
c'était pas le sujet la violence des
groupes manifestants est une violence
ciblée et qui par ailleurs vise des
banques des des des des
banques et des assurances et donc c'est
légitime parce que ce sont des banques
ou les assurances je ne parle pas de la
question de la légitimité je dis que en
fait faire pleurer sur le commerçant
dans la vitrine et brisée est en fait
une erreur et que par exemple dans les
terrasses de café moi j'étais dans une
terrasse de café à un moment où il y
avait une manifestation le le cafetier
avait très peur pour ses clients et pour
sa terrasse et en fait effectivement il
y a eu un moment où les gens sur sa
terrasse se sont retrouvés en situation
dangereuse mais parce que ils se sont
fait gazer et chargés par les
manifestants par les manifestants pardon
par les forces de l'ordre votre avis non
mais enfin il y a une autre dimension
qui que l'on voit très bien quand on
n'est pas alors dans la théorie mais
quand on est dans les manifestations ou
derrière les policiers parce que ça
m'arrive aussi qui qui encadrent ces
manifestations c'est d'une part la
surprise que peuvent avoir certains CRS
et gendarmes mobiles on l'a dit quand
des interventions de brave viennent
désorganisé leur dispositif en ce sens
là il y a pas toujours une homogénéité
des policiers ça a été dit mais c'est
important de plus en plus on voit c'est
distorsion entre l'appréciation faite
par les gendarmes mobiles ou les CRS
d'un côté et les braves de l'autre avec
même des des discussions assez
virulentes et puis l'autre chose c'est
que ce qu'on oublie c'est qu'au début
des manifestations on a eu très
clairement des tentatives de feu de
poubelle ou autre qui ont été réglés non
pas par les policiers mais par les
services d'or des syndicats et ça on
l'oublie un peu trop et que cette
présence policière parfois
elle vient plutôt ajouter sommet de la
perturbation alors que les
manifestations même dans une certaine
mesure c'était pas le cas des gilets
jaunes parce qu'il y avait pas de
service d'ordre des gilets jaunes mais
les syndicalistes ont des seins des
services d'ordre qui peuvent servir à
justement ne pas laisser se développer
la question pourquoi ce à partir du
effectivement des 49.3
les services de sécurité des syndicats
ont été voilà déborder aussi efficace
des services de renseignement sans doute
une responsabilité collective c'est
justement c'est ces mécanismes
collectifs réciproque qui sont
intéressants c'est clair les
renseignements enfin le service de
renseignement avaient anticipé annoncé
qu'on allait avoir à faire à des
manifestations plus violentes ce en quoi
ça ça c'est pas toujours révéler exact
alors on parle des uns les autres de la
braver mais donc je voudrais qu'on se
concentre encore un peu plus sur ce
point précis donc unité mobile à moto il
y a évidemment un conducteur un autre
policier derrière je propose un
témoignage solide un manifestant qui
dénonce des interpellations abusives de
cette unité et puis aussi nous raconte
comment ils sont intervenus regardez on
s'est poursuivre on se fait les motos
arrivent de manière assez assez
impressionnante donc les gens se mettent
à courir les les mecs descendent de leur
moto ils nous courent après ils nous
tapent j'ai été frappé au visage du coup
j'ai tout de suite miné main en l'air
parce que j'avais mes lunettes je
voulais pas qui me met en plus me
détruisent mes lunettes mais ouais
impressionnant ça fait un soir au sol on
certains se sont fait insulter on
pouvait même pas te poser de questions
il nous est notaire et que en gros on
allait avoir ce qu'on allait avoir quoi
et puis on a tous été emmenés au poste
on a un
ils sont que j'étais moi à Paris en
manifestation je manifestais contre la
loi de vaquage j'étais étudiant et lors
de cette manifestation un jeune homme
appelé Malik ouakine a été tué par une
brigade qu'on appelait les Voltigeurs
c'est pas exactement la même chose les
bras même mais ça ils ressemblent quand
même frédéric est si pourquoi est-ce que
pourquoi on a besoin des bravesm
même si je peux entendre votre votre
comparaison si je puis dire elle est
profondément inexacte ce ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes types d'unités le
policier qui va être conducteur de la
moto cyclette c'est un motard celui qui
est derrière lui c'est un fonctionnaire
de compagnie d'intervention les
compagnies interventions à la préfecture
de police on a évoqué la spécialisation
des unités leur professionnalisation en
maintien de l'ordre et c'est resté
gendarmes mobiles les compagnies
parisiennes ont une expérience et une
formation qui est aussi elle très
exigeante et donc on n'est pas sur des
gens qu'on va ramasser comme peut-être
l'été à l'époque les Voltigeurs qui
étaient notamment des moniteurs des
moniteurs d'activité physique et qui est
concenté qu'on sortait de temps en temps
sur les manifestations donc vous dites
mieux formés en tout cas ce ne sont pas
on n'est pas sur les mêmes modèles en
tout cas et moi j'ai un peu l'impression
c'est juste la longueur de la matraque
qui rappelez-vous aussi rappelez-vous
aussi du contexte cette unité a été
créée au moment où on avait les actions
les plus agressives de la part des jaune
et où le la mobilité de ces groupes a
nécessité une adaptation c'est quand
même la genèse de cette de cette unité
je reviens juste sur un point sur c'est
sans doute par idéal révolutionnaire que
vous évoquez le fait que les
manifestants ne ciblaient que des
banques et des et des symboles du
capitalisme oui et les forces de l'ordre
et les forces de l'ordre en général ce
type d'individu se réconcilie sur le
fait de casser du flic lorsque l'on
parle d'interpellation arbitraire quand
on interpelle avant les manifestations
certains individus qui arrivent les bras
chargés de cadeaux pour les policiers
avec des hommes par destination avec des
marteaux avec des boules de pétanque
avec des projectiles fait de manière
artisanale avec des vis qui dépassent
je crois qu'il faut pas être candide ces
types d'individus il faut les
interpeller ils sont là pour semer le
désordre dans la manifestation et le mot
d'ordre de la manifestation je pense
qu'à la limite ils n'en ont rien à faire
ils sont des objectifs bien précis c'est
de semer le désordre et je pense que
toute personne raisonnable
sachant que ce genre d'individu il faut
les dissocier des manifestations il y a
plusieurs pétitions qui ont été lancés
sur le site de l'Assemblée nationale
pour obtenir la dissolution on va dire
de la braven
Mathilde Lay vous pourriez les signer
bien sûr je les ai signés et il y a
plein d'autres problèmes pourquoi il
faut pourquoi il faut suspendre ou
interdire les bras même pour vous mais
parce que la bravem est je le redis
créatrice de désordre il y a une autre
problème à la brave
des manifestants violents et très
mobiles on n'a pas besoin de de motards
pour les arrêter non il y a d'autres
moyens de les arrêter en revanche toutes
les interpellations la grande majorité
des gens après avoir passé des garde à
vue qui sont extrêmement humiliantes je
sais pas si vous avez vu le témoignage
d'un étudiant en Master de de
M1 en sciences politiques à Paris enfin
tout le département c'est mobilisé pour
le défendre qui raconte des garde à vue
enfin avec un niveau d'humiliation de
violences verbales d'humiliation raciste
homophobe et la plupart des gens sortent
absolument sans rien sans aucune charge
et les quelques-uns qui ont des charges
c'est des charges qui c'est parce que
pendant la garde à vue ils ont refusé de
déverrouiller leur téléphone où ils ont
refusé de donner leur ADN et donc ils se
retrouvent envoyés devant le juge mais à
cause de ces infractions commises
pendant la garde à vue mais quand ils
ont arrêté ils n'avaient rien fait
l'autre problème de la garde de la
braven et c'est là ça c'est la
spécificité de la brahime c'est qu'elle
intervient avec une appréciation
immédiate sur le terrain c'est-à-dire
que l'on coupe la chaîne de commandement
elle travaille en autonomie la bravehem
donc ce sont des unités qui vont
intervenir sans avoir un contrat ou un
ordre enfin en tout cas un accord de la
salle de commandement qui est la une
vision générale et c'est aussi ce cette
autonomie de la bravenne créateur de
désordre alors la différence avec les
avec les Voltigeurs qui est souvent
évoqué c'est que les voyageurs de Pasqua
il tapait en roulant alors que là il
descendent de la moto mais en même temps
Malikou c'est Kim qui par ailleurs on le
sait n'avait rien à voir avec la
manifestation puisqu'il sortait d'un
concert et rentrer a été tué par des des
Voltigeurs qui étaient à pied donc le
fait qu'il ne tape plus en roulant n'est
pas une garantie votre avis sur
spécifique vraiment sur cette brabelle
la conserver est-ce qu'elle peut être
efficace dans certains cas dans
certaines manifestations le contre
certaines violences le problème je vais
redire ce que j'ai dit sur la le
décalage entre le théorie la théorie et
la pratique et vie effectivement quand
il y a une manifestation le problème est
toujours d'aller capturer les individus
qui sème le désordre sans sans prendre
les autres manifestants en otage ou
autre et donc on a toujours ça fait très
longtemps qu'on se pose cette question
là en terme de maintien de l'ordre
comment on va réussir à faire ça donc
l'idée pourquoi pas le problème c'est
qui on est allé prendre on est allé
prendre les compagnies d'intervention
des gens qui de travailler dans les
banlieues et de travailler de manière
rugueuse pour ne pas dire plus en tout
cas de manière offensive c'est des gens
qui sont pas là pour négocier pour
discuter qui sont là pour aller au
contact au contact physique etc donc on
a rempli ce besoin avec des gens qui
n'étaient pas forcément adaptés ils ont
une formation ok mais ils sont pas en
symbiose avec notamment je l'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois les autres forces de
l'ordre et en plus ces gens là on leur
demande de faire du chiffre pour prouver
qu'ils sont existants donc c'est l'autre
problème structurel de la police
française la culture du chiffre et quand
ils arrivent pas à interpeller des gens
et bah pour justifier parfois ils
interviennent en décalage et on a vu des
gens se faire interpeller trois quatre
heures après la manifestation je vous
interrompre parce qu'il nous reste 6
minutes et il y a un thème important
dont il faut absolument parler dans ce
débat c'est la question de de
l'identification des policiers et des
gendarmes mis en cause depuis le début
du mouvement de contestation contre la
réforme des retraites la Défenseur des
droits a été 90 signalements pour des
violences policières mais et on va
recevoir retrouver Alexandre poussat
rebonsoir Alexandre dans ce débat sur le
maintien de l'ordre il y a plusieurs
personnes qui dénoncent le fait que
beaucoup de policiers ne portent pas sur
eux le numéro de matricule on appelle ça
le rio quelles sont les règles en la
matière alors déjà le rio ça signifie
référentiel des identités et de
l'organisation c'est le numéro
d'identification à 7 chiffres de chaque
agent des forces de l'ordre chaque
policier aux gendarmes se doit de le
porter c'est une obligation depuis 2014
alors sauf pour les policiers qui
doivent rester anonymes dans l'exercice
de leur fonction et si un agent des
forces de l'ordre ne respecte pas cette
obligation de porter le Rayo et bien il
encourt des sanctions disciplinaires
cela va du rappel de la règle à
l'avertissement le rio ça permet
notamment d'identifier un policier ou un
gendarme dans des enquêtes
administratives ou judiciaires mais le
problème c'est qu'une partie des forces
de l'ordre ne porte pas ce Ray en
intervention et ça a des conséquences
entre novembre 2018 et octobre 2020 il y
a eu 456 enquêtes judiciaires confiées à
l'IGPN l'inspection générale de la
police nationale parmi elles 295 ont été
classés sans suite par le parquet et
dans ces enquêtes classées sans suit et
bien un tiers là a été car le policier
n'avait pas pu être
identifier d'où l'importance de porter
ce numéro de matricule et d'ailleurs au
début du mois d'avril ça a été rappelé
par le sénateur socialiste Jérôme Durin
lors de l'audition du ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald de Darmanin écoutez
la question du rôle de Jérôme Durand
cette question qui pourrait paraître
accessoire ne l'est pas pour deux
raisons d'abord l'identification des
policiers intervenants dans le cadre des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
apporte beaucoup notamment s'il faut
retracer la chaîne des responsabilités
en cas de manquement déontologique
ensuite cela est perçu à raison par la
population comme une évidence que l'on
puisse
identifier les policiers alors que
comptez-vous faire monsieur le ministre
pour augmenter le port du Rio au-delà
des rappels de cette oblig il y en a eu
18 depuis 2013 vous allez le voir le
ministre de l'Intérieur général de
Darmanin a fait une sorte de mea culpa
sur ce sujet alors que le jour même et
bien le 5 avril le Conseil d'État devait
se prononcer sur ce non port du Rio par
les policiers certaines associations
demandant un renforcement à des
sanctions écoutez Gérard de Darmanin
j'avais raison il y a des policiers des
jambes qui portent pas leur
immatriculation bah c'est effectivement
au contraire on règle vous avez rappelé
vous-même d'ailleurs qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de rappels règles faut-il aller
plus loin écoutez on va y réfléchir si
le Conseil d'État considère qu'il nous
faut nous en joindre de le faire bon moi
je vais attendre la décision du Conseil
d'État et comme toujours avec le droit
parce que je suis républicain démocrate
j'appliquerai les règles de droit et me
plaisent ok me plaisent pas et bien au
final dans sa décision le Conseil d'État
a reconnu quand même que le port
obligatoire du Rio n'avait pas été
respecté en différentes occasions
notamment en particulier lors
d'opérations de maintien de l'ordre mais
le Conseil d'État ne demande pas un
renforcement des sanctions en cas de non
port de ce numéro d'identification et il
appartient selon le Conseil d'État et
bien aux autorités hiérarchiques autant
qu'au responsables d'unités de rappeler
et de faire respecter cette obligation
sous peine d'une sanction disciplinaire
donc au final le ministre de l'Intérieur
s'est contenté d'un courrier adressé aux
policiers pour leur rappeler de bien
porter ce Rio notamment le 1er mai
prochain lors de la prochaine
manifestation pour vérifier ça
évidemment avec nos équipes sur le
terrain
Frédéric les 6 c'est c'est de la
mauvaise volonté
il n'y a pas vraiment de sanctions
appliquées alors votre votre chroniqueur
l'a évoqué de les sanctions existent le
ministre de l'Intérieur a rappelé pas
plus tard que vendredi dernier un
certain nombre de principes du sMMO du
schéma national de maintien de l'ordre
dont celui-ci le numéro de la même
identification du Rio doit être portée
c'est une obligation la hiérarchie
veille et lorsque ça n'est pas fait les
rappels et les sanctions et les enquêtes
administratives c'est passé par des
policiers il y a de la mauvaise volonté
vous êtes en train de manifestation vous
êtes en train de généraliser le Conseil
généralisé de la même manière vous avez
aussi toute une série d'éléments
d'identification qui sont là justement
parce que le rio reste quelque chose qui
est de taille assez modeste vous voyez
j'en porte moi même un sur mon épaule
celle-ci elle peut se cumuler un CRS va
avoir des bandes jaunes sur son casque
un policier de sécurité publique des
bandes bleues et le sMMO a prévu et
c'est en cours de généralisation sur les
éveillés de sécurité publique un
marquage avec un flocage dans le dos
l'unité et le groupement il y aura
peut-être du progrès il nous reste une
minute donc je vous demandais très
rapidement Mathilde Lasserre pourquoi ça
vous semble essentiel et parce que
justement
l'absence de d'identification participe
du sentiment d'impunité qui favorise les
violences il y a la question des
cagoules aussi on revient à la bravème
les bravesmes ils ont le casque et la
cagoule et et alors que à nouveau dans
le schéma national la cagoule
normalement n'est pas autorisé elle est
proscrite pour des forces de l'ordre or
on a des forces de l'ordre cagoulés qui
sont donc qui ne peuvent pas être
reconnaissables donc si on n'a pas rien
que ça ça entretient la la l'infinité et
et il n'y a aucun contrôle aucune aucune
suite à des violences policières qui
sont nombreuses sont les manifestations
alors je dirais pas aucun parce qu'il y
a des procédures mais peut-être pas
suffisamment merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat à bientôt sur
public c'est la voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission merci encore à toutes et
à tous de votre fidélité à Sens public
je vous dis à mardi puisque lundi c'est
férié vous retrouverez également cette
émission en replay et puis toutes les
autres tous les autres programmes de la
chaîne évidemment sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr belle soirée
à toutes et à tous
[Musique]